[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality dr john
deloney is my co-host today and we will
be talking about your mental wellness
your relationships as part of everything
we do because that's what he does on the
dr john deloney show every day you can
be sure to check that out what's
actually three days a week as a podcast
a
hugely popular podcast on ramsey
networks right now so be sure and check
all that out phone number here triple
eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
donny is with us in fayetteville north
carolina hi donnie welcome to the ramsay
show
man it's an honor to talk to you you too
sir what's up
dave i'm in a pickle
all right
uh
i'm 53 years old
have absolutely nothing for retirement
i'm 50 000 in debt
and i want a divorce
[Laughter]
okay
what what's
going on with your marriage yeah sounds
like you're in a jar of pickles man what
you got a jar of pickles yeah what's
going on with what's going on with the
marriage
well
it's i guess it's just been building
over the last 10 years um
you know just
i'm an over the road truck driver and uh
hardly at home
now my wife was handling all the bills
and and all the money and
um for a while man we were doing great
right covet hit
i was at home
and we got debt free paid off everything
we had so you're saying you all got
along better when you weren't there
oh yeah we definitely get a lot better
one on my home oh yeah
that's why i've been married for 32
years
that's that's so not funny but i'm sorry
well it is funny actually
but i mean you know last year i mean i
was in a sweet spot we were in a sweet
spot no debt i had six months living
expenses uh saved up i had money uh we
didn't have to you know use credit cards
anything she wanted all she had to do
was go buy it you know we were we were
set
and then
all of a sudden she just got a wild hair
up her
upper britches and wanted to move into a
house and
doubled our rent
emptied the savings
and then she got crazy and went and got
all these credit cards and and started
putting charges on them
and
a couple of weeks i found out i'm 30 000
in debt to the tax uh to the irs
for years of taxes that she didn't pay
and i guess i should have been a little
more on top of it but yeah a lot
yeah
you know
so now all of that just hits me and and
you know of course
the marriage has sort of been going
downhill for the last 10 years and
and no but it wasn't though when y'all
were on the same page and y'all had
y'all were able to sleep again and you
were able to laugh and do something
together again it wasn't so the last
couple of years it's been pretty good
right
or did y'all come up with this common
purpose we're going to work really hard
together we're going to get out of debt
we're going to do this we're going to be
set up and it was still failing then it
was still falling apart then i don't buy
it
yeah yeah the marriage was still falling
apart but we were on the same page as
far as finances go
i had approached her with the snowball
program and and and
and introduced her to dave she was
reluctant and uh you know i just sort of
i just sort of put my foot down and said
you know look this this is the way it's
just got to be and and this is what it's
going to look like when we're done
and
she she trusted me and so we started
doing that and we achieved our goal
nope nope you didn't no you didn't you
didn't achieve your y'all's goal you
achieved your goal
true i'll give you that
i'll give you that
and so she got debt free
for you and then you went back on the
road and she's still sitting there and
she went with her
nowhere right
right
yeah you're right
[Music]
and i'm just
you know i mean i've been in full panic
mode ever since i turned 50.
you know let me ask you this let me ask
you this what what is the actual
this is a sad situation i'm sorry donnie
um it's a mess and there's a lot of a
lot of things we could deal with in the
mess
a lot of pickles in the jar and um but
what how can we best help you
today
i need to figure out something to do
with these taxes
okay
all right that the the taxes not being
paid is a symptom the credit card debt
is a symptom
the debt getting paid off
is a symptom
of behaviors and attitudes and beliefs
that you all are
harboring or not harboring and so
um i'll be happy to tell you what to do
with the irs you need to go to
ramseysolutions.com click on elp for
taxes sit down with one of our tax pros
and they'll help you negotiate a payment
plan with the irs until you can get them
paid off now
then what at the core of this whole
thing
is that you guys suck at communication
in your marriage beyond belief
yes
and it's partly due to you being on the
road it's partly due to you putting your
foot down
only you missed
when you put your
um you stomped on her toes and yeah all
you did is stop on her toe you didn't
really do anything and uh it's partly
due to her doing whatever she wants
you you guys so then what you've got to
do is you're going to continue to have
financial problems as long as you are
not communicating and aligned on where
we are going and align doesn't mean
you're demanding or she's demanding
aligned means we both look into the
future we see a desired future that we
both agree on and then we both agree on
the steps to get to it
we both have a vote and we both are
going to put our shoulder to the wheel
and we're both going to push that's the
only shot your marriage has otherwise
you are divorced
and then you get to go fix your money
problems
and you know
you said that all those things were a
symptom
and of of the behavior
and i agree with that because i mean i
follow you man including your behavior
including yourself because you're not
plugged in enough to know that the taxes
weren't being paid that's a behavior
and you'll have a dance of the y'all
y'all are doing the dance of the victims
where she did all this to me and then
he's on the road to left me and then he
[ __ ] about the way i do it and then
we're back y'all are
hey you want to get out of the dance of
the victim walk up and take a knee
and take ownership and say here's what
i've contributed for the last 30 years
and i'm willing to change
that's that's the shot you got right
yeah
take ownership of it if you guys can get
in alignment and an agreement you got a
really good shot at straightening up
your money stuff and your marriage
absolutely
but if you're not then you just gotta go
decide what you're gonna do after you're
divorced
and get after it but get in touch with
one of our tax elps and they'll help you
with the tax mess brother i'm sorry
you're facing this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
number one best-selling author
of the book own your past change your
future dr john dolone ramsey personality
is my co-host today chris is with us in
new york hi chris welcome to the ramsey
show
hey james how you doing great how can we
help
so i called you about a year ago um
i uh just a silly win of where i am
right now i'm uh i have full-time
full custody of my daughter
i work full-time and i have two
part-time jobs
um
i work i'm looking to buy a house and
from what i'm listening to everyone all
the financial
people that i hear on the radio are
saying wait one year
about a year it should be about the
right time to buy now my question to you
is i have i work for a good company
they were offering me this first time
home buyers program i'm not um
i'm not 100 sure if that's you know the
name of it but uh that's basically what
it is and uh
they uh they said all i need basically
to buy a house
is uh three percent and the cost of the
down payment uh not the down payment uh
three percent in the cost of the quote
uh the closing cost
do you think that's a good idea
well i don't know what the terms of the
deal are uh there's lots of different
kinds of first-time homebuyer programs
out there three percent plus closing
costs is the same thing an fha loan is
yeah what's the benefit there's no big
benefit to that that i can hear
um are you debt free
yes sir i am good and you have your
emergency fund in place
yes sir okay then if you can buy a home
and if you get into this further and
figure out that it's a great deal
uh if there's some other benefits to it
but it sounds like it's just an fha loan
to me i don't know what it i don't know
what their what the company is
contributing in their program that they
have you got to figure that out because
what you described there is nothing
special
i yeah i believe they said they they
would help uh pay 25 000
towards uh off the um the cost of the
house
okay well that would be a lot yeah
that would probably cover a lot of your
down payment right
uh yeah my question is uh when do you
have to repay that or do you
i don't think i do it's a pretty good
company they they uh it's a bill it's a
lumber yard we're the biggest on long
island and uh they uh they said they
would contribute to uh the economy out
in long island and uh they they want to
help out their employees um pretty
strong they uh
yeah
as far as as far as the experts saying
to wait a year i wouldn't
because the house prices are going to be
higher one year from now than they are
now
you think they're going to be higher i'm
almost positive they're going to be
higher
well they well they're saying like wait
because they uh there's a lot of those
that are stupid
yeah
hey chris as a guy who just sits by dave
um he uses this weird thing called math
and
data and it's unnerving sometimes but
usually it's right
yeah so i mean here's the deal we have
uh one-fourth of the inventory
available that we had in 2008 and we
have 6x the buyers
that we had in 2008.
now 2008 house prices went down because
their supply demand curve
was not what it is now but right now
what i'm explaining to you is is there
is a greater demand than there is a
supply in that case with any item it
never goes down in price
when lots of buyers are chasing few
items it always goes up in price that's
how we saw a 29 increase in 2020 and 18
increase in house prices in 21
22 appears to be seven to eight percent
what we're going to end at and 23 is
projected to be four to five percent
increase so the talking blabbering fools
that don't know that data are who they
are that are you're listening to you can
do whatever you want to do i'm
not going to affect me at all but i'm
not waiting a year to buy a house if i'm
going to buy a house waiting on it to
come down you're going to be sorely
disappointed if you do sounds like you
have a very unusually cool company
i've never heard of a company paid 25
000 for somebody's house before
and i've been doing this 30 years i've
got a very cool company we do a lot of
unbelievably cool things for our people
and i haven't done that one and i was
about to say dave where were you on that
one man
nope not that cool not as cool as his
company if that's the definition of cool
so yeah i mean wow pretty impressive all
right samuel is with us in houston hey
samuel what's up hey dave hey john thank
y'all for everything you do and so far
to talk to you sure what's up
uh two years ago i had a good paying job
a family three kids a house and um
uh no debt and about ten thousand
dollars in savings or so um
around that same time i went through a
very bad divorce um had to resign for my
job to care for my three kids but i have
full custody over
uh we had to relocate i live now in your
family and so things are better and over
the the last six months i've got myself
you know back to where things are you
know no one's starving bills are paid
etc um
during that period i
very very foolishly uh borrowed quite a
bit of money
and i'm in a hole and my question for
you all pertains to two particular uh
personal loans through lending club
amounting roughly to about fifteen
thousand dollars um the interest rate on
those to both those loans
let me stop you i wanna make sure that
everyone hears real clearly what you
just said lending club was not a
blessing
no okay i'll just make sure folks
understood that okay
because they're so sweet they're so
sweet i mean like sofi right they've got
all these little sweet people doing
little dances in their commercials and
crap and then when you actually talk to
their customers they go they screwed me
so just make sure everybody loud and
clear i want to put names with that okay
now so you got 15 000 in debt and your
income went before all hell broke loose
in your life was what
it was uh fifty thousand dollars a year
uh i'm actually thirty thousand dollars
in debt and that is at a thirty thirty
five percent interest rate um it goes up
every day i made a plan yesterday to pay
it all off uh by may of next year called
them to walk through it and found out
that my projections were wrong because
uh today if i were to pay them a day i'd
be paying them thirty thousand dollars
if i pay them yeah yeah so
what did you do
what did you say you used to make
fifty thousand dollars a year and what
do you make now
um
i'll be lucky if i make 25 right now
okay
uh what did you used to do sir
i was a music director
um
church musician and um i
the the gig i was in was particularly
sweet i got in there through some major
connections it wasn't no it really
wasn't
50 000 a year doesn't fall in the bucket
of particularly sweet it's okay it's
great but
i i'm sure 500 thousand dollars a year
falls under the head of hitting a
particularly sweet so um
so what you you know what you've got
really dude is two things you have a
structure problem with the debt
and the second thing is with having the
hellbeat out of you for the last three
years you've kind of stopped believing
in you
yeah
i remember that feeling when i went
broke it took me a little while to start
believing in me again
from the trauma
is that okay
yeah that's okay yeah because there's a
bazillion jobs out there right now that
pay more than the stinky one you've got
uh dave if you don't mind my putting
this out there i that i'm currently
working two jobs and right now it keeps
us afloat and my obligations to my
children i mean everything is working
it's just the debt that's killing no the
reason the debt is killing you is you
don't make any money
yes that's true if we can double your
income this problem goes away very
quickly and we really should be able to
without destroying your family life
but you're white knuckling trying to
make math work that doesn't work
yeah and it's that's why you called
because it's not working it's blowing
your brains up right i mean you're just
like you're scrambled eggs
and so i i remember this feeling it's
stress induced
so uh anyway
let me let let me step back a second and
but number one i'm gonna tell you that
what i'm gonna do is go apply for 10
credit cards and get five of them and
move this debt from freaking lending
tree which now it sounds more like a
payday lender the way they're screwing
you over you've got to get this off of
their books and move it somewhere else
where it's more of a normal if you had
an 18 credit card debt it's be superior
to what you got now
it really would
so let's go get some credit cards and
then i'm going to send you a copy of ken
coleman's book i'm running out of time
john i'm sorry but um i wish we had more
time with him
paycheck to purpose dude you've got to
work on the income side of your equation
you've got to believe in you enough
again to go get better jobs
the ones you have are horrible lots of
things out there paying 20 25 right now
target is paying 25 and they suck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
delony ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage wes and lindsay are with us
hey guys how are you how's it going
we're good awesome where do you all live
we're in castle rock colorado oh nice
fun welcome to nashville how much debt
have you paid off
215 000. all right how long did that
take
38 months all right and your range of
income during that three years yeah we
started at 120 and then ended at 185.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a stay-at-home mom and a grad
student
and i run a planning and development
team for an oil and gas company in
denver ah and it's obviously done very
well in the last 36 months good good for
you or at least you've done very well
good proud of you very cool what kind of
debt was your 215 000
it was her house you paid off your house
weird people
how old are you two
i'm 35
and i'm 38 and you're paid for house
in castle rock colorado what's it worth
660.
[Laughter]
how much is in your retirement accounts
guys
right at 400. so right at being baby
steps millionaires ding ding look at you
and not even 40 years old
tell me this stuff doesn't make you
wealthy people are listening the people
listening
like you can't even talk you're smiling
so big
like this is exciting i can feel it
through the glass this double pane glass
right yeah you're just radiating this
excitement that's awesome
so proud of y'all very cool you did this
fast too
very well done all right tell us what
happened how did you get connected to
the ramsey way
about 10 years ago a close friend of
mine was leading fpu and uh even though
she'd been
prodding at me to to go
uh he convinced me so
of course of course yeah okay and so uh
but you only did this for three years so
what happened to the other six years uh
we got we started paying our house off
when we went through fpu and then i got
transferred
so we had to press pause for a little
bit and then we got transferred back to
colorado and uh that's when we started
okay and then when you when you landed
there and everything does settle you
said okay we're doing this for real that
was 38 months ago game on yeah yeah we
were leading an fpu class and it's oh
it's really easy to to get motivated to
pay off debt when you're
teaching this stuff so yeah
that's so good
that's so good well done you two yeah
it's a little difficult to lead the
class and not do the stuff that's kind
of hypocritical yeah yeah all right so
lindsay lindsey take us back to the
moment when wes comes in and says hey
i've been talking to my friend dan he
thinks we should uh
walk us through that conversation
well
his name's tim
timmy
i was trying to help him out but i know
um so
tim
suggested we go through this class and i
had been
trying to
get him to do it for a while and then we
finally went through it he listened to
his friend above me of course
but um yeah it was it was awesome we
finally got on the same page and like
like he said it took us a long time to
to finally get to the point where we
wanted to get gazelle intense on our
house but
a few years later we decided to
to do it and now you don't have a
payment in the world nope
how's it feel to not have a payment in
the world and you're not even 40.
feels like peace yeah it's it's awesome
it's absolutely awesome you know what
you can do when you don't have any
payments and make 185 000 a year
anything you want
wow
pretty impressive hey unpack that word
peace i um that sometimes i think we've
gotten to a place in our culture where
peace is is like a unicorn i don't even
know what that looks like i don't see
one of those in real life
describe that what's a couple of things
that have changed in your life
oh gosh um
so during covet when oil went negative
that was not a time of peace when i had
a lot of debt yeah
and for the last five years we've gone
through rolling layoffs about every six
months and uh
knowing that if that happens again
that we're just perfectly fine i mean i
could get a job at walmart it's gonna be
annoying not catastrophic yeah yeah and
that is an inconvenience yeah it is
really peaceful to know that there's
nothing weighing on our shoulders in
this category yeah
what's the first big thing you're gonna
do to celebrate
well we kind of already did we promised
our kids that
you know we'd sacrificed so much when we
were on this journey and they're still
pretty young and
we told them that we would take them to
disney world when we got our
house food off and so we we got to do
that and that was awesome
but the biggest thing is i bought a new
washer and dryer yeah
[Music]
that's how you celebrate right there
that's big celebration
wes you didn't you didn't buy that for
christmas did you no i didn't i
[Laughter]
oh you guys are incredible i'm so proud
of you what is the thing you tell people
when they learn that you are 100 debt
free if they learn that if they learn
that your baby steps millionaires and
they say how'd you do that you're not
even 40. what do you tell them the key
is
for me the the key has really been
intentionality and contentment
and just less consumption just less
financial consumption but also less
uh
social media consumption less hgtv's
consumption
both of those things make you want to
buy stuff yeah
and just really um being thankful and
happy with what we have i like to say
the phrase comparison is the thief of
joy
and for me that was really true so when
i just became content with what i had
and
uh that was a huge part of this how it
worked for me is that a craig crochelle
or a rachel cruz quote rachel one of
those two is that rachel cruz quote i
don't know who says it one of those two
said that yeah we'll say rachel cruz
yeah there you go probably is because of
her book love your life not theirs
probably in that so wow way to go you
guys so proud of you
who were your biggest cheerleaders
oh our whole family was uh they're
really you know
not not many of them have gone through
fpu but they're all huge supporters
uh they're
i mean every single one of them was
rooting for us they're probably watching
right now and they're probably all
pumped yeah so have you and then we've
got some best friends who went
through the class when we were teaching
it um desiree and adam
shout out
so yeah and my favorite thing is looking
at those three beautiful little kids and
go ahead and bring them up
most people don't understand like yeah
they're not gonna have debt growing up
but they're gonna have a mom and dad who
aren't always worried what if we get
laid off and we're not gonna we're gonna
have a mom and dad who's worried if we
get a flat tire this thing's over with
stress level in the house is approaching
zero right yeah and um dad's not gonna
be yelling at the little league coach
because he's got peace in his life he's
not angry at teenagers right it's such a
gift yeah way to go guys hey we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
copy a total money makeover you can give
those away in your financial peace class
because you're all of these things also
going to give you a financial peace
membership you can give that away and
get somebody else started on your
journey if you want
since it helped you guys so much that's
so cool what are the kids names and ages
this is hannah and she's six this is
jonah and he's four and this is naomi
and today's her birthday she's turning
nine happy birthday naomi awesomeness
very cool very cool you guys have
absolutely changed their family tree
you've changed everything i'm so proud
of you absolute rock star couple man
you're absolutely amazing well done well
done well done all right it's wes and
lindsay and birthday naomi and hannah
and jonah from colorado 215 000 paid off
house and everything
while becoming baby steps millionaires
did it all in 38 months making 120 to
185 count it down let's hear a debt free
screams
three
two
one we're done
[Music]
this is how it's done
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well with the rising cost of everything
these days a lot of folks are worried
about having enough money in their bank
accounts to get through the month
too much month left at the end of the
money
the good news is no matter where you're
at with your money and no matter the
state of the economy
you actually can get on a path to
building wealth
at our building wealth live events
you're going to learn simple
common sense principles of course
that build wealth put you in a position
to be outlandishly
generous and not at the um not with
inflation uh you're under the thumb of
inflation
or recession or whatever other negative
words we want to pull out of washington
wealth building tour is blowing up we've
already sold out two nights the rest of
these events are on track to sell out
really really soon if you're thinking
about joining do not wait
uh september 13th in phoenix is already
sold out sacramento november the first
is already sold out we added a night in
phoenix it's almost sold out september
the 12th november the 10th in
minneapolis san antonio has like six
tickets left or something like that it's
almost gone november the 15th
passes start at 25 you can get a four
pack starting at 60. so bring some
friends load up come down to building
wealth
it's all the ramsey personalities dr
john not all but dr john dolone ken
coleman me rachel cruz and george
campbell we'll all be there and uh you
know we're beyond the lobby signing
books taking pictures all the stuff and
uh also uh you know doing a panel we're
gonna do all kinds of stuff so it is a
great night and we'd love to see you in
phoenix sacramento minneapolis or san
antonio if you get tickets before
they're gone kelly's with us in orlando
hi kelly welcome to the ramsey show hi
um how are you good what's up
um
so me and my husband have been
talking about me
leaving my job and coming to stay home
with our kids
we had kind of come up with a little bit
of a long-term plan for me to work into
into the beginning of next year and kind
of try out our budget in the meantime
without my income
but i have impending um
you know opportunities and promotions
training things like that kind of
happening
at work and i'm feeling a lot of
pressure
and i'm wondering
you know if we move that timeline up how
many months is
good to try out
you know on on just one income how much
is your house payment
uh
mortgage is
about 1500. yeah and what's his
take-home pay
um
he
works on commission a lot but um we
think his uh now what did he pay taxes
on last year
um
a hundred thousand
i hear one of two things either
you
are
getting encouraged to stay at home and
you don't really want to
or you want to be done right now which
one is it
it's um
it's in between i
i do want to be home i want to be home
with my kids but i i guess i in a
position where
a lot of people are depending on me and
you know all these like trainings to get
me ready for things and it's it's making
me feel really anxious you're feeling
like you're not having integrity
yes
you don't feel pure taking all this
training knowing you're not going to use
it
yeah yeah and if you tell them what
happens
um
i guess the best case scenario is they
let you work for the end of the year
we've got this plant yeah they let me
work to the end of the year in the worst
case scenario if they let me go
yeah yeah
and your experience around the place
tells you they'll do what
i don't know i don't know
how long you've been working there
eight years okay they get pissed off at
fire people like this or do they have a
little grace what do they do
you know what they do
um
most people who work there have worked
there for a really long time um i i want
to think that i have a good enough
relationship with my
superior that
you know she would
understand yeah okay
first rule is you have to be a person of
integrity
that's what's bothering you more than
anything in this whole conversation
okay
and then the chips fall where they fall
okay let me tell you what's going to
happen
nothing that's what's going to happen
because what you just described to me is
a very stable workplace these are not
people who are rash and angry and
throwing around they don't treat people
poorly
otherwise you don't have a whole bunch
of people live been there eight years
people don't stay
if the leadership there sucks
okay so you've got you've got something
you can count on there you're just
worried that you're not going
you just had a baby win
uh
i've got a three-year-old and a
six-month-old yeah okay
that might enter into a little bit of
anxiety yeah and can i ask you a hard
question
are you sure
do you trust that your husband's gonna
go work really hard on this commission
deal or do you make the majority of the
money and as part of this you're afraid
to jump onto the boat because you don't
know if it's going to be super stable
oh no he's he's a hard worker he's
wonderful awesome well that's that's you
need to you need to you need to tell
them that you're thinking about leaving
at the end of the year you're not 100
sure but i'm i'm 70 or 80 sure and i
didn't feel right about not telling you
this because of all the training and
stuff that's coming up and i didn't feel
right i if i if the roles were reversed
i would want to know if i were you so
i'm treating other people like i want to
be treated by telling you that's ethics
yeah okay and then see and then more it
lands where it lands but i'm going to
give you an 80 to a 90 probability you
work through the end of the year and you
don't do all the training because
they're going to appreciate your
integrity and these are not rash people
that are it's not a toxic work
environment
okay does that give you peace
yeah yeah um i mean we i guess we had
kind of thought about moving the
timeline up to maybe trying out the
budget well you need to start trying out
the budget today from today forward as
soon as you get off the phone you need
to start banking your check
don't touch it put it in a separate
savings account run the budget on his
check
starting today
never use any of your money from your
work ever again for your house
hardcore like it doesn't exist
they put it in savings and don't touch
it no cheating
because it's not going to be there after
you quit at the first of the year
right
yeah yeah you're going to make it you're
okay how much debt have you got
none good yeah go through christmas go
through thanksgiving just your check
yeah you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine your house
payment's not out of line that's why i
was asking i was trying to figure out if
you could afford it on his
income or not and here's what happens is
um when you take the training wheels off
and dad let's go with the seat you will
balance the bike
yeah you will you will it's it's amazing
and then it'll freak you out a little
bit that you're actually doing it and
then you'll rack and then you'll get
back up and down you'll do it yourself
right but here's the thing don't touch
your check ever again
yeah we wrote out the income like to ch
it was like kind of this just happened
very quickly this this decision it's
like i just tried it out one day it's
kind of been a long time goal and i just
tried out the budget one day without me
and without daycare and it just worked
out yeah i would think it would work
i would think it would 100 000 a year
with a 15 100 house payment and no debt
i would think you could be able to make
it
it should
work
okay it's not a hot knife through butter
but it's definitely not on the stress
level
and
you're you're all twisted up right now
post pregnancy you're all twisted up
about this integrity thing because you
are a person of high honor
and not telling them is really riding on
you
am i right
yeah yeah that's what's bothering me
yeah yeah you need to go tell them
tomorrow
and you need to bank every check that
they give you until the end of the year
or until they fire you and live on his
check you can do this
okay you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine and if if they walk
in they say get out of here we never
liked you anyway good riddance
yeah all right take your soul take your
soul and spirit out of that place yeah
and then go and if you have to do some
kind of part-time gig or something until
the end of the year
and do do some side hustle stuff till
the end of the year we'll be dupty
you can do this you can do this you
didn't give me any numbers that tell me
that you have to do it differently but
let me tell you what integrity people
who have integrity win at money
[Music]
you are a high person of integrity you
are going to win at money
long term there may be some bumps along
the way but you're going to win at money
i've got tons of data to back this up
and 30 years of experience you can do
this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
open phones this hour dr john deloney
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the dr
john dolone show is my co-host today we
will be talking about your life and your
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five jay is with us in charlotte
north carolina hi jay what's up
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
calling to be as quick as i can okay
other than my mortgage my wife and i
have no debt of any kind we just built
our we just built our dream house the
balance on the mortgage is 550. um i'm
sitting on about 500 000 cash and so my
question for you guys is do i take a
substantial amount of this money and
just do a recast and new my monthly
mortgage payment do i take a substantial
amount of money and invest it in mutual
funds we do have retirement accounts
or you know do i just sit and hold all
of it i don't think that's the best
strategy my wife and i really don't feel
comfortable
um with having less than a hundred
thousand dollars in cash just because of
the nature of my job and honestly we
don't have any children yet and we want
to have at least one child
what's your household income
last year we made right at 350.
okay what's the nature of your job that
is unsettling to your wife
well i'm in real estate uh full-time and
it's been great but you know i do see
the market turning where i am and you
know you just can't count on selling 40
plus zones a year every year for the
rest of your life you know it's it's a
bit of a work-life balance and if we can
have a kid you know i'm going to take my
foot off the gas at some point i'm not
there yet but that's the long-term play
okay
all right let me uh
i i'm going to assume the goal is uh
what is the short the answer to the
question should be based on what is the
shortest distance between where you are
and wealth
and the shortest distance between where
you are in a high quality of life
if those were the same answer then we
would go with that agreed
yes i would agree with that pay off your
house
okay as soon as you can
put 500 on it today or 400 on it today
or 450 on today take a big chunk of your
wonderful income and finish it off by
spring be a hundred percent debt free as
soon as you possibly can now let me tell
you what's going to happen and why i
said that then you get to decide if i'm
right okay
in studying 10 000
plus millionaires the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
and in 30 years of sitting in the seat
walking with people that have become
wealthy
the data shows us very very clearly that
the typical millionaire in the first one
to five million dollars of net worth has
two things they have a
beefy
consistently funded over a 10 or a 12
year period of time plus
401k roth ira plan
in good mutual funds
and they have a paid for house
that is the typical
case of all of them that we've studied
now there's exceptions but the vast
majority fall they have those two things
almost none of them said we didn't pay
off our house we invested the money in
mutual funds not in a retirement account
and that made us wealthy
that is a theory that all but that a lot
of people talk about and actually almost
no wealthy people do it
right
so the shortest distance from where you
are to millionaire based on the data and
the experience i have is pay off your
house as soon as you possibly can and
then continue to steadily invest in your
retirement the second thing that's going
to happen that is not from the data but
is from personal experience as well as
experience of sitting in this seat is
what you don't realize as a
self-employed person and as a
salesperson to boot is that when you
have zero debt
your swagger changes
the way you walk changes
the way you deal with clients changes
the way you get rid of high maintenance
time sucking horrible clients and don't
take them makes you available to take on
the good clients you will end up making
more money because you're peaceful
and you are more selective and you're
careful and a broke salesman smells
different
than one that's not that's right
you're gonna make more money because you
paid off your house
it's hard to grasp that but all of my 30
years of experience indicates that
that's the truth and i'll throw one more
at you okay number three
um
your wife
sits in some she's got 500 000 in a
checking account and she still has that
little voice saying we're not safe we're
not safe we're not safe
if something happens if the market turns
if something goes sideways we're not
safe we're not safe
take all of the risk variables off your
table
then you don't need a hundred thousand
you all have never breathed air where
you owe nobody anything
and suddenly you don't need a hundred
thousand dollars because if the market
turns and you only sell 15 houses
there's nobody starving right you're
gonna you're gonna have to change your
lifestyle a little bit but all your
bills are covered right it changes the
air you breathe in your home which makes
you laugh a little bit more you sleep a
little bit different you don't skip as
many workouts you don't
your whole rhythm changes when i
got a net worth in excess of 10 million
dollars and had zero debt i did not work
less hard
i just worked less desperate
oh you should write that book
you know i still i still work you know i
work my butt off yeah i work all i love
i love what i do so i'm down here all
the time i'm but i i absolutely have
zero arithmetic
mathematical reason
to
work yeah zero yep
and uh i'm not bragging it's just this
crap i teach works that's right that's
right i've been doing it a long time so
uh it just it
sometimes sales people sell a lot and
work really hard and have bad work life
balance and it's desperation and
sometimes they do it just because
they're freaking good at it
and they like it i mean they're peyton
manning tom brady man they just get her
done and it's just a thing of beauty to
watch
you know they're in a zone they're
artists
with what they do and it changes your
brush strokes
it just does man and you just you hit
the ball different you throw the ball
the whole thing i'm telling you it
changes everything and it's hard to
grasp that and that is for those of you
listening in on this conversation which
is all of you except jay because it was
with him but jay go pay your house off
shut up but no then anyway but
that's part of we were talking about
this in a meeting a little bit earlier
the borrower is slave to the lender now
we throw that around and we go okay yeah
when you have to when all your money
comes in and you have to give it all to
the bank that feels like a slave right
so the bible's telling the truth in
proverbs 22 7 right and so but you know
here's the thing you need to take on is
what are the character qualities and
lifestyle and mental health of a slave
they're trapped they don't have any
choices right everyone else makes their
choices for them they've got no freedom
they've got no peace they don't breathe
their own air it's impossible to be
generous right
your slaves are never generous you know
you're met a generous slave i'm not a
slave so i don't know but you know but i
mean think about it the thing about the
concept of the what slavery does to the
psyche yeah
what slavery does to your psychology to
your body it takes everything it's
generational right it goes on for it
keeps going you don't even know it
because you get so used to it that even
the people of israel want to go back to
egypt yeah because your your your spirit
is damaged
at that point and and we don't grasp all
of that when we're just talking about i
want to get out of credit card debt it's
great get sally may out of the house
she's a witch get her out okay but but
what happens
to your life and your spirit
it's a big
big subject
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're listening to
this show there's a good chance you
finally had enough
of where you are in life right now
enough mediocre relationships enough
being stuck in meaningless nine to five
j.o.b.s enough struggling to pay for gas
enough struggling to pay for groceries
enough to make too much to be this broke
the truth is nothing's going to change
until you
change it
so this month we're bringing back the
ramsey 10 sale you can get up to 83 off
our number one best-selling books
and tools that'll help you finally take
control like the total money makeover
know yourself know your money
own your past change your future by dr
john deloney questions for human cards
by dr john dolone i've got a new quick
readout called the momentum theorem
or if you're looking for a career change
to grow your income pay off your debt
check out ken coleman's resume templates
so
ten dollars you can finally say enough
is enough enough
go to ramseysolutions.com today and
check out the store you'll see what's
going on our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
they are the number one online retailer
for custom window coverings when you
deal with them you'll see why you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more always use the magic word
the promo code ramsay
alright today's question comes from jane
in wisconsin my daughter is 15 and has
recently experienced some mental health
challenges i'm concerned about her
ability to manage the money her
grandparents have been investing for i
currently manage the account but it will
transfer to her when she turns 16.
should i
allow the account to transfer to her but
hide the login details
or transfer the money into my name until
she turns 21.
both feel morally wrong and maybe
illegal is there a legal way to ensure
she can't access it until she's 21.
so dave my
i just operating rules never lie to your
kids
um
this is complex because her child's
obviously struggling with some
challenges here um i don't know the
legality
you've probably seen this question more
than i have um i don't know why you can
hide something that
transfers to a kid but also this kid's a
minor yeah so the k it doesn't transfer
to the kid
you're confused somewhere okay um
all bank accounts all mutual funds uh
for people under 21 have a custodian on
them
an adult
or 18 or 21
18 21 depending on the state whatever
but i mean you're not 21 for mutual
funds um you're not
able to enter into contract law which
opening a savings account is in any
state in the union when you're not an
adult there you go yep and so now the
the
trust may transfer to her the
uh whatever but she doesn't suddenly
become the owner of a million dollars
and 16 years old or whatever this amount
of money is it just doesn't happen now
but i'm with john just tell her the
truth
hey i'm walking with you through these
mental health things
and you don't need the pressure of this
right now the money is yours it'll be
there for you you'll have access to it
when you are healthy and you are able to
make good decisions with it and like
when you're an adult
nobody's going to do anything with it
i'm not buying me a new car with it i'm
not doing anything like that the money's
there it's yours sweetie it's okay and
it may be only a thousand dollars i
don't know what it is we don't know from
this and sometimes people get it in
their head there's a lot of money it's
not immoral and it's not illegal to care
for your children they're minors
it's immoral and to not care for your
children or to hand somebody who's
struggling a million dollars yeah it's
not ethical now if she was 23
now you've got all kinds of issues
well you really don't have anything
moral and legal
i mean
you can't do that then you just you just
have to talk to you you could say
you could offer to
become her power of attorney until she
gets well but that you do that for your
friend who's 32 also you know and so
but but you've got a minor here
and
they just um they have a right to
uh
uh ethical treatment they have a right
to nurturing they have a right to
nutrition they have a right to not be
abused
but they don't have
have ownership rights
as minors right
my car
by the three-year-old is not actually a
true statement
well and i i think we forget sometimes
dave
had this negotiation with one of
rachel's the other day i imagine but
we've all agreed as a society
um we think you should be 16 before you
get behind a 3 000 pound metal missile
headed down the highway we uh let's
let's wait till you're 18. let's wait
till you're 21 for some of these me
but then we turn around and we just ask
kids to make so many heavy decisions or
what do you want to do when you're 15
years old or 14 years old
man they need adults in their lives yeah
to help keep them well it's okay it's
okay to uh
have give them information but not the
weight right
yeah i'm gonna carry this for you it's
gonna be here for you when you need it
yeah
but you don't get to you know you're not
going to go buy
a 50 000 car because grandma gave you a
hundred thousand bucks right you're not
gonna do it and because you're not
capable of making that decision and so
someone will be assigned as the
custodian
until she's 18. there's currently
someone
i currently manage the account but it
will transfer to her when she turns 16.
um
i don't know where you got your
information jane but something's
confused here hey let me ask you this if
she took that money and rolled it into a
529 is that a way to shelter it from her
kid and save it for college
i don't know what the source of the
money is okay and whether uh whether
that's gonna be okay i i i just think
you just say no yeah i don't like
stealing i don't like you're doing
heroin and i'm not giving you any money
yeah sue me
you know
and uh if you wanna if you wanna
you know go live somewhere else or
whatever and you wanna get a lawyer then
you can do that i guess but
um but i'm not giving you i'm not going
to assist you in harming yourself yeah
and you know misusing this money is
harming you and the future you and i
just love you too much to let you do
that and so
you know a another version of that we
always said was
uh we had
uniform transfer to miners act
which is before there were 529s that's
how you save money it's just all that
means is you open a mutual fund in the
kid's name but you're the custodian just
like we're talking about
and uh parents would say always say well
i don't know i mean my kid turned 16 or
turns 21 i mean what if they're doing
heroin i would just go well technically
they're 21 it's their money i guess
they've got a well-financed heroin
addiction or you can just look at them
and go find it
i'm stealing it
you know that's technically illegal
right but i mean what am i gonna do i'm
gonna take care of my child right and if
some of you don't like it screw it yeah
you know i'm doing it anyway so no i'm
not gonna let you kill yourself because
i saved money for you
that's dumb
so uh and sometimes the culture is dumb
call dhs everybody does so why not you
know why not you too so um you know have
at it baby good luck with that let's see
how it turns out for you you're still
none of you're gonna find it because i'm
the only one who got the codes
and so
and i'm just that guy you know cause i
just i'm just gonna it was my money to
start with right that i gave you and now
we're not going to let you you know so
you just kind of have to have the old
school parent idea of like i'm in charge
right and i'm and i'm going to love you
even when it's hard
yeah the inmates don't run the freaking
asylum at the ramses
all right up next uh savannah in olympia
washington hi savannah how are you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um i have a question about a potential
job change for my husband's and what our
next steps should be
we are almost finished with baby step 3a
and my husband is looking at moving
divisions within his work we are unsure
if the pay will be the same
um
he is excited for this new opportunity
but it feels like it and he feels like
it would be a better fit for our family
because it's a telework position
my husband's current position is
demanding overtime hours where she is on
the road anywhere between three to five
days a week and it is negatively
affecting our family
financially our rent and expensive
expenses has increased dramatically over
the past year and there isn't a lot of
wiggle room without overlapping
stop stop stop stop stop
why did your expenses increase
dramatically over the last year
um rent um has increased almost 800
and um we have our one-year-old is now
um
eating and um we are now from what is
your husband
what is your husband mike
he currently makes 90. and what would he
go to if he took this job do you know
you don't know
what do you have
what's the worst case scenario
the worst case scenario is that we lose
20 000
okay a year okay here's another one
c
none of the above
go get a job where he has a life and
makes 90.
he doesn't have to stay with his company
back yourself into a corner you feel
like you you've narrowed yourself down
you have only two options
geez there's nine million places you can
work why do you only have two options
no
change jobs
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage jeremy and becky
are with us hey guys how are you hi dave
good good welcome where do you guys live
denver colorado welcome good to have you
guys
we're glad to have you how much debt did
you pay off 125 000. whoo how long did
that take 23 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
um we start at 65 and then up to 150 and
now around 110. awesome
so uh what do you guys do for a living
i'm a physical therapist
and i'm a quality engineer okay so you
turned it on to get out of debt and then
turned it back down so you could have a
life we had a baby oh there's that
okay i'm part-time um and i'm home with
my daughter that's a good life to have
right there i like that life so what
kind of debt was this 125 000 my grad
school student loans
all of it all of it straight up sally
mae she's out of the house decided to
kick her out so we could have a baby
that's right i like it need to have room
sally you gotta leave it's only a two
bedroom house we needed extra space for
the baby that's it sally you can't stay
i like it i like it i like it so uh what
happened 23 months ago how'd you get
connected to this whole ramsey way thing
well it was a little bit before that we
got gazelle intense 23 months ago but
right before that my husband lost his
job
and then we realized oh my gosh
we have a lot of debt this is not good
and then kovid of course and then
everyone thought that they were gonna
lose their jobs including myself and we
were like this is really bad and we had
we had to read your book
um
we had gotten really the really old
school fpu from a patient of mine um and
then we did that but then beginning of
kovids you did um the free two-week fbu
trial so we we just blew through that
and said let's do it
instead of netflix we binged fpu that's
better than tiger king it was we missed
tiger king yeah we did fpu instead you
missed nothing
oh way to go you guys so that got you
completely geared up and ready to go and
23 months game on jobs come back in and
you just start smacking the thing around
yeah so everyone stayed at home and and
i got two extra jobs i was working 12
hours a day whoa yeah
yeah we were we were really going so wow
yeah i'm glad to know what's your baby's
name bridgette and how old is she she
turns one year in two days okay so kind
of in the middle of this bridgette comes
along yeah yeah so you're working like
crazy while you're super pregnant yeah
she was yeah i slowed down a little bit
as one does when they start to waddle
shuffle side waddle yeah that's it yeah
i like it that's good that's a good good
phrase that's good very that's smart you
so you guys just i mean how long y'all
been married
it'll be six years okay yeah six years
so two years of the six years you've
been doing this stuff and then covid of
course is part of the sentence right uh
but covid and all this and yeah it's
like something like we have to have this
qualifier and everything we do for at
least the next five years or so and then
we'll move on and
forget about uh well anyway yeah let's
forget about it so now um
let me ask this uh the
i'm gonna throw this out there and feel
free just to dismiss it okay
but i hear this a lot doing debris
screams for the last few years when it
comes to one person has a lot of um
student loans
there ends up being some shame on the
part of the person who has the student
loans and there becomes a little bit of
frustration that i'm having to work like
crazy and i kind of lost my wife because
of these her student loans how did y'all
navigate that because it's just hard
it it was hard i would it definitely was
hard um
you know i i had just paid my deciding
to be honest
she's holding my hand but there's
millions watching
yeah i had just paid my student loans
off a couple years before that and you
know
when i found out because i didn't really
actually know how much she had when i
found out and we started this journey
together i was just like oh how are we
going to do this there's there's no way
it just seems like a mountain we can't
climb yeah
and we climbed a lot of mountains in
colorado yes we did
but we just
i mean finding fpu and just buckling
down and
chipping away at it you know
it kind of puts all the uh
emotions of shame or uh resentment
either one in the rearview mirror when
you got a goal exactly oh yeah yeah and
knowing that she loved her job too um
you know it was worth the
yeah worth cleaning up the mesh yeah
exactly very good you guys well done
proud of you thank you who are your
biggest cheerleaders
i feel like everyone thought we were
really crazy at first because everyone
you know especially during covet they're
like why are you going out why are you
working like you need to stay home and
quarantine like yeah but i cannot live
with like this anymore and then as the
ball got rolling i think all of our
family jumped on board you know um my
mother-in-law and sister-in-law are here
today celebrating with us so that's good
it took a it took a minute but i think
everyone was pretty excited afterwards
yeah once they realized how much we did
in one year they were all like oh wow
this is possible yeah
how hard was it making that kind of
money and driving the used car
the car reminded us a lot because i feel
like i had to keep taking it into the
shop to get it fixed we we cash flowed a
lot of stuff during this time too yeah
paying for the baby
um dogs acl surgeries dogs
costs a lot of money thank you she's
cute oh yeah yeah her knees she had two
knee surgeries during all this
dogs are expensive
they can't they can be yeah especially
free dogs yeah that's pretty much that's
exactly what this is you know i never
had a free one that ended up that way
so way to go you guys so proud of y'all
well done very well done we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you uh
that's the next chapter in this story
for sure you're on your way total money
makeover you can give that away to
somebody maybe who is a doubter maybe
you can get them on your team now and
get them going and also financial peace
university a one year membership and uh
the the since you've seen it there's all
brand new videos uh not all but largely
dr john deloney and george campbell
rachel cruz and i are all in there now
and uh it's really really strong so go
back through it if you want or give it
away either one whatever you want to do
it's all good and uh so very very well
done now what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that is
don't give up
just
don't give up no we we had to make major
changes to our lifestyle um but we did
it together i feel like
having having a partner and you can do
it without you know a spouse too but it
was really nice to have someone there
on the same page and really working
through it together the built-in
accountability the built-in
encouragement yeah is really cool yeah
it's working that way it's working right
i mean we made some other you can you
you've probably been mortified we've
learned being in nashville that there's
a lot of really great meat and yummy um
like chicken like nashville hot chicken
and stuff but we became vegetarian
during all this to save money
and um and minimalists to save money too
so yeah that's all good it's beautiful
we love the life we live now and you get
to choose what you want to do that's
what that's what this is about yeah yeah
you have a lot of freedom to make
choices out amen didn't get them let's
worry all right is bridget gonna be in
the shot with us while we do a debt-free
scream you want to bring her in oh it'll
be maybe a debt-free whisper she's
really tired we don't want her to be
but we do need to celebrate your
incredible milestone well done jeremy
and becky and bridget denver colorado
125 000 paid off in 23 months making 65
to 150 to 110
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three three two one we're dead
free
yay
[Applause]
she made it
great
[Applause]
this is how it's done
this is how it's done i love it i love
it i love it
doesn't get any better than this
so proud of you guys
very very one of my favorite things is
when
somebody makes a choice
i'm gonna set down my shame i'm gonna
set down my resentment and you mentioned
you gotta have a goal and i think you
gotta have a plan something you can uh a
track you can follow i'm gonna take a
couple steps i'm gonna take a little
step up take a little step and then
we're gonna get there together but it
took two people so i'm gonna set this
thing down and quit carrying it and i
just love that yeah and then it's in the
rearview mirror yes does your move on
because we're going this way yeah that's
right i love it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book own
your past change your future is my
co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two
mitchell is with us in salt lake city hi
mitchell how are you
how's it going guys thanks so much for
having me on sure what's up
so
um my whole life i've been
pretty financially stable i would
consider myself a frugal person
um recently my world got turned upside
down um my wife and i we just had
triplets oh whoa
yeah yeah that's usually the reaction i
get from people
um and it's just really just thrown a
wrench in what and how i've been
planning financially so
um a few months ago well november of
last year we got pregnant and right
around that time we had bought in
our first house it was actually a duplex
and the numbers were so good on the
duplex that we could actually live in
one side completely free the other side
was actually paying for the whole
mortgage and some so we were planning on
living in the duplex
for years a long time
not having any
um not having to make any payments we
have debt obviously but we were
comfortable with the debt in that house
and then when we found out we were
having
triplets
um there's just no way we can fit in
there it's really it's really small
it's old and we just don't want to raise
our family in there so now
currently
we are
under contract to to buy our first house
and i'm just freaking out because i'm
not i hate that and i just feel like i'm
making a bad financial decision but i
just wanted to reach out to you guys and
see you know what your thoughts are on
on what i'm doing did you sell the
duplex
so we haven't sold the duplex um because
now now we have renters on both sides
i'm not currently living with my parents
and they're helping us with the with the
triplets sell the duplex and
sell the duplex yes
and even so and the cash flow on the
duplexes so right now cash flows if they
pay
you're right they don't always pay
you have stress because you're carrying
a bunch of debt that you can on a rental
property that you can't afford
and if it does if it doesn't work it's
going to go sideways and you're you're
you're feeling that in your chest
along with the weight of two three
triplets standing on your chest
yeah
so so you're right there that stress
does i mean yeah i'm just stressed all
the time
no matter what the scenario is i'm just
stressed out well it's because you're
trying to keep everything you're trying
to keep the past dream and and stitch it
to the future new reality and they don't
fit together
dump the duplex move on with your brand
new awesome life but it's a completely
different life than your little plan
ever you you haven't got it through your
head yet everything is different now
oh no
yeah
yes he does
i know that everything's different so
how much is the house payment on the new
house going to be
so
the on the new house the payment would
be about 31. 3100.
100
nice 3 100
3 100 on the new house and what is the
household income take-home pay
so household income so my wife currently
she's not working she's she's full-time
mom she had triplets yeah yeah she's for
sure working dude
oh i know she works a lot harder than i
do and i let her know that she's not
working outside the home okay yeah so
what do you make dude
so i'm doing about two to three hundred
thousand a year you're fine sell the
duplex
here's what's going on okay
you are i because i'm you that's how i
can just it's easy for me to read this
because i'm i'm like a super planner
i mean i i know what i'm going to be
doing in march right now
okay it's ridiculous how how
ridiculously
anal i am about this i mean i just i i
love having a plan i i when we go on
vacation i know what we're going to be
doing the whole time on vacation or it
is not relaxing to me
yes
it's not relaxing to me to not know not
knowing is stressful for me okay you're
that guy you're like that right
i i'm the same person you had this all
dialed in
and the car hit the wall i mean it was
like nascar engine up in the stands
doors flew off your plan just
disintegrated
thank goodness it was for a joyful
reason
yeah no they're a blessing but it
completely you're it just you know so
now what you've got to do is you got to
regroup and it's going to take you a
little while to sweep the corners out
of all the wreckage
and now build a new plan with the new
situation and you make a ton of money
you're in a great situation you got
three wonderful babies you've got a
wonderful wife wanting to take care of
them and now you've got a nice house to
stay in instead of that cheap butt
duplex you had stuck your wife in making
300 grand
yeah
i i haven't even mentioned yet that we
also need to buy a van because they
don't fit in our cars so save up and buy
a little cheap van or pay whatever you
can save up whatever you can pay cash
for
and then move up a little bit in van
later and get a little better one later
that's the other thing is people these
these these triplets
are teeny tiny little humans
and we feel like oh i i'm bringing home
a 12
um
pound human or a 10 pound human or a six
pound human they need their own bedroom
their own furniture set their own
they don't they don't take up a mushroom
they don't yet right they will but they
don't you've got a few years they need
three car seats
that's a sedan that's right you know be
uncomfortable and annoying and all that
but you can do it right yep yep yep yep
you're gonna be fine mitchell you're
just going through congratulations
you're in shock yeah you're just going
through shock i mean you're you're a
planner and your plan got destroyed yeah
and until you get your plan rebuilt
you're going to feel the stress and it's
going to take you a little while to get
accustomed to the
new rhythm of life and put the plan in
place and then you're going to be there
but i mean it's what you say all the
time you gotta grieve the thing that you
what you thought it's gonna be it's not
gonna be so you gotta you gotta you have
to grieve that and go i thought this
kind of yes i'm i can't say out loud
babies suck but three of them at one
time
it's hard it kind of sucks a little bit
you know and then there's then there's
awesome all the awesomeness but there's
a little bit of you that goes ah that's
right you know and so that's reality and
that's okay but you're not allowed to
say that out loud i know i'll get
trashed on twitter just because i said
that so yeah it gets fresh on twitter
every day that's exactly right hey so
let me ask you a mechanic's question um
let's say he was gonna profit a hundred
grand from the sale of this duplex yep
it'd appreciate that much yep
would it be best for him to take let's
i'm assuming his house payment is
probably about five hundred 000 is gonna
be his mortgage so would it be better
for him to
put a hundred thousand dollars down and
drop that thirty one hundred dollars a
month to twenty eight hundred dollars a
month or to just go ahead and make the
loan and then immediately dump a hundred
grand on top of it because i think he's
already got the house okay no no no he's
under contract it's under contract yeah
if you get the duplex hold in time put
it as additional down payment and have a
smaller payment because that would be
like because that's a i would throw it
all if it's unless you need a little of
it to buy a van but there you go the
rest of it i mean let's be de he said he
was debt-free so what kind of van are we
gonna buy making 300 grand i mean go go
get you i like the idea of collapsing
that uh monthly payment as much as i can
yeah yeah well i always put everything
down on the house i can above the
emergency fund
and above in this case a new van and the
second and third baby bed and so
whatever it is you gotta buy right and
so it's it's just it's a thing but
mitchell you're going through
a normal human adjustment
to a shock to your system
and that causes stress right
and if you didn't feel
all of this in the form of stress you
would be psychotic you go see a doctor
right yeah and so you know normal humans
when they go through what you have gone
through have a ah
moment you know that you know just so
the good news is you're normal right and
let's chip chip away at it right because
if you're a planner you've already
started thinking oh gosh i'm gonna have
to have a hundred thousand dollars a
semester for these three and so don't go
20 years down the road and start
creating catastrophes that you've got to
solve today
just start following the plan chip away
it didn't chip away at it
old minister was working the
altar and a
friend of mine young boy came forward
and years ago and told me the story he
became a pastor later
and he said this guy was a visiting
evangelist and he went up and he asked
for prayer he said i'm having i'm 14
years old and he said i'm having lustful
thoughts about girls and the minister
laid his hands on him and he prayed lord
thank you this boy is normal
[Laughter]
just
relieve you of the stress yeah i mean
you're normal mitchell i mean this is
what you're in you're in this situation
and so you're normal thank goodness
you're okay
now you're going to work through the
things that are causing you anxiety
limit them develop a plan cut loose the
old stuff from the old dream the duplex
is gone and we move forward into the new
journey
and then everything will calm back down
and you'll get your little planting self
together i know this because i have to
do it all the time
this is how i live my life so i'm right
there with you brother
good question and congratulations
mitchell way to go mitch happy three
times over awesome this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and have actual
amazing relationships dr john deloney
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two
five
david is in la hi david welcome to the
ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
i need your advice
because i'm on the verge of making a
serious life decision
i'm currently in the process of buying a
condo with
the mother of my children
we're not married
we've been together for 10 years
the thing is like i said we're not
married or engaged and i don't plan on
asking her to marry me anytime soon
i want to get your advice on what you
think we should do because like i said
we are in the process of uh buying this
condo
okay
well um
all of the data that i know
uh regarding a situation like yours the
the legal problems that that what you're
entering into is going to present you if
things go sideways
um the uh
the future uh
prosperity of this family unit
uh tells me that
uh marriage is your best answer
uh now
i'm curious if you're willing to have
babies with her and buy a condo with her
those are both very large decisions why
would you not marry her
um
that's a great point it's just mainly
you said it kind of like as a flex like
i'm i'm not married to her i'm even
gonna ask her to be like like dude
you're already married like you
you're doing all you're doing all the
time
like you're you are you are connected to
this woman for the rest of your life
it's like a technicality now yeah what
are you doing like what are you scared
of because i just feel like every time
uh we get to
like at the finish line
uh there's just something that brings me
back and it's mainly just like um she
has a terrible problem with
communication
not just with me but um dude it's too
late to find that out if you bought a
condo and had three kids you made humans
together bro it's
the ship sailed
now you get to decide whether you want
that ship to to
to be in the harbor and have smooth sail
in the head or it to be a disaster
you're already out and you're already on
the water
so let me tell you that like my my
mental aspect of how i uh how i see the
the future then right
no no here's what you're saying i don't
want to marry her i just want to buy a
house and raise kids with her together
for forever
well the thing is like i don't i mean
yeah we've had kids together um
and i've been doing my best you know to
keep
i want i want to raise my kids i want my
our kids to be in the family oriented uh
you know environment then make a family
make a family
seal it up so you're saying just put up
with like whatever no no no no no
no no no no no no dude you're gonna put
up with them anyway everybody
if you live with her with kids it's the
same woman
yeah whatever problem she's got whatever
problems you got they're gonna be there
already hold on let me ask i think i get
what you're asking
you're going to buy a house and y'all
are going to live there together
but you're going to see other people who
are going to make you happy
no
no you're going to be true to her
it's because
yeah and i've been these ten years okay
they've been together it's just the
other day
the other day i saw um
uh one of uh a youtube video dave ramsey
and uh he was kind of going in on the on
the girl because she was uh getting a
place with her fiance she wasn't married
yet
and i thought to myself like whoa like i
wonder what he would say to my situation
because okay here's what i'm saying
here's what i'm saying i would get
married because dude you already are
married you just haven't technically
done it so yeah
okay now here's what that does it does
several things uh one is it affects your
relationship and it affects your alls
it's the last like you said over the
finish line it's the last step over the
line and it's gonna force you guys to
deal with the relational issues you've
got number one but number two the reason
you actually called was this
it solves all your legal issues
because what you're doing under
california law is you i'm not an
attorney but this is the truth if you
call an attorney
is you're forming a general partnership
and and both of you are on the deed and
both of you are on the loan and if you
have a blow up
and she takes off
you've got this thing and you can't even
sell it without her signature
and you can't find her because she's
hiding at her uncles in idaho
or vice versa exactly
exactly but if you are married then you
would be going through what's called a
divorce and there's a process for
handling this deed
and getting the property out of your
all's names but you don't have the legal
thing is like
vastly more complicated when you're
shacking up than when you are married in
every state even california which is
immensely complicated but even there
okay and so yeah uh but and on top of
that um i'm just being your old ugly
uncle boomer uncle right
and and and i'm just loving you and i'm
saying hey yeah man i i you know i i
love you david and i want you to have
the best life for you for her for those
kids and all the data and all the
research indicates
marriage trump's shacking up for the
high quality of life the likelihood of
wealth building the
propensity to succeed in your career
all of these things are accelerated the
research piece the researchers call it
the marriage advantage
they find that people who are married
versus people who are single whether
shacking up or not have an advantage
an economic
advantage over a period of 30 or 40
years we see a lift among the marrieds
um versus the singles
i'm not picking on you singles i'm
quoting research to you right this is
actual freaking data and stuff like
truth in other words and so that's what
you know
you know and so yeah that's a thing and
so what we would tell you because we
care about you not because we're
thumping you with a bible or something
like that we're just they said there's
just it just works better life works
better this way and you're doing it all
anyway you just got to admit this to
yourself and let me
let me lean into something you mentioned
here brother
you said am i supposed to just take this
no the answer is no the answer is you're
telling me she's got a communication
problem and you know what she probably
does i trust you and if i sat down with
her she would say i've been with this
guy for 10 years and he and i'm not
coming i'm not good enough i'm unsafe i
feel like i gotta yell to get his
attention i gotta scream and then you
hear that as communicate and now y'all
are in a dance so you wanna you wanna
path forward here's the path forward you
walk home and you get on a knee not to
not to propose to say i'm sorry
for ten years i've sent you a message
that this is what your value is i'm
always going to hold you to arm's length
until you get i'm going first and i'm
sorry yeah and i'm asking you can we
learn to communicate in a different way
so that we can get married and move on
with our lives together and the last way
to look at this is if one of those three
kids is one of your daughters
how do you want them handled david
[Music]
would you put up with this
for on behalf of one of them for a
decade i would have run you off if he
was around one of mine
because you didn't know whether painter
get off the ladder
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book own your past change your future is
my co-host today you've heard the news
we're in a recession the stock market is
falling inflation's out of control all
right everybody calm down
if you're investing this is not a time
to panic
breathe
don't jump off the investing roller
coaster because of the gloom and doom
nobody gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off in the middle
of the ride
history shows us that the economy
recovers time and time again
it has owned all the great crashes in
this season even one of the great
crashes
this is just a little it's all this is
you ready
hey if you need help finding an
investment pro who can walk you through
this teach you about it
check out our smart vester program it's
where we have vetted pros who serve with
excellence they'll be there to help you
figure out what's best for you
and they do it with the heart of a
teacher so
you then
learn
why you're investing where you're
investing and it works for you
ramsay solutions solutions.com smart
vester
if you want to do investing in mutual
funds it's a good time because they're
on sale right now
the market's down yeah it's a sale
they're having a sale right now don't
miss the sale
and that's the way you look at it when
you're investing long term boys and
girls so ramsay solutions dot com smart
vester
so john
more people now live together
that are not married than live together
that are married statistically okay
demographically speaking
and so when we take a call like that
then of course uh we will get the hate
mail for the next several weeks in form
of social media comments and so forth
about me being a fuddy-duddy which is
actually accurate that's a hundred
percent accurate 100 true
and so you're not really it's not really
hate mail it's just an accurate thing
but here's the thing okay so
i i remember when uh
my kids were in college and they were
dating
they're they're serious
people that they're going to marry kind
of thing
and
i started kind of wondering about
because i didn't have the benefit of any
of this i just got hitched you know
and so i didn't have the benefit of this
so here's some interesting numbers you
hear that 50 of the marriage is in
divorce you heard that yep okay
that is number one not true not accurate
okay but yeah but what is interesting
statistically is this
if before you get married
you graduate from college
both of you
if
both of your parents are still married
to their original spouse which you don't
control that variable
okay
if
you uh end up with a household income in
excess of 50 000 a year
if
you have children after you are married
not before you are married
if you have children after you are 22
years old
not before
you are 90
likely to stay married if you have those
variables wow
isn't that interesting yeah so when
you're here
all the marriages make sense all the
marriages fall apart what you're dealing
with is
16 year olds with
virtually zero education all kinds of
economic problems no incomes
and shacking up and kids everywhere and
you're mixing that in
with the people who are living life in
order so to speak you just you painted a
picture of stressor after stressor after
stressor after stressor that are removed
that yes that then then you have to do
i don't know anybody who enters into
marriage and it all just works out how
you thought it was gonna work out never
but if you enter into
this this relationship and there's all
these other stressors if you have a
level of education a level of income and
you did things in the right order and
you come from a background of that kind
of thing oh the other one is if you
regularly attend a religious service
yeah
jewish muslim
christian
catholic whatever whatever whatever
denomination you know all that regularly
attend you if you do that boy it goes
way up right it goes way up so uh people
that don't have any kind of faith walk
at all
uh they they don't have the uh
skills that you develop when you're
when you're in an academic rigor
they don't uh have the income they've
got the right now does that mean you
can't make it of course no it doesn't
mean you can't make it i'm just saying
when you take about four or five of
those variables out of the equation your
likelihood of divorcing is very close to
zero and so we'd like to blame the
institution of marriage this is our
culture now is just pull apart every
institution
we want to blame marriage and actually
there's this line of stressors
right
um that we can it is a better represent
representative of what's actually
happening here so that's why i like when
that young man calls and they're getting
ready to buy a house they're you know
they've got three kids now they did that
that they did one of the two of those
out order i don't know what his income
was i don't know his education level was
i don't know what their background was
as far as their parents goes so i don't
know all those things but i do know
several of the variables right there
that indicate he's probably going to be
successful but he's afraid yep and he's
stressed he's afraid he's afraid that
that he's not going to do this right
so for 10 years he's been standing one
foot on the boat one on the dock
and it can't make up his mind whether
he's going to go on the trip or whether
he's going to stay home right
and um
you know that that's the thing and it's
it's it's
and what ends up happening is
those kids are being raised in the
environment
and then they're set up for the same
things it's not to pick on him but these
are these are things that you talk about
changing your family tree right
some people talk about breaking the
family curse yeah or the things you know
my whole family if you say i hear people
say my family's been in debt all the way
back as far as we can find i'm the first
person in my family tree in that in that
can we can ascertain that's ever been
dead free i hear people say that that's
not true for me but i hear people say
that
and uh so they broke the chain they
broke the curse or i'm the first person
to graduate from college
or i'm the first person to
wait to have kids until i was married
right
i'm the first person to regularly attend
a religious service in our family tree
you can start to see these things how it
breaks the curses
of that how it breaks the things off but
those are choices that you get to make
folks that's right you get to choose
this yeah and you can choose so what i
loved about that piece of research was
is that gosh i could tell my kids this
stuff and say if you do this stuff in
the right order this is like a formula
or a at least a
a probability you can increase your
probability of success by doing this you
can increase probability success by
doing that you can increase your
probability of success by doing that and
then they can they can live that out
because of that knowledge base right and
so when the storms come which they will
yup
i've got as few stressors in the
pipeline as possible yeah based on some
of those choices that's i love that yeah
yeah and and uh so
it's it's a big deal i mean
it it's
it's pretty scary out there so i you
know a lot of people are have a lot of
different views on these things but
it's not a
for me i i'm
yes i'm a person of faith and yes i'm a
christian and yes i uh you know i'm
going to tell you what the bible says if
you ask me for sure
but the uh uh the other thing i like to
look at is i love finding the data
that kind of supports
the assumptions of my faith right i
don't have to just go on the assumptions
and so that's what i'm talking about
here in other words god talks about
being married
you know
one man to one woman hello hello he
talks about that and so when you
actually function that way you know it
you can as you can assume as a christian
person that goes okay then god said do
it right yeah that's good and i do
believe that but it sure is cool when
you can find all this other stuff out
here in the actual
research that goes oh that must be why
he said that
[Music]
because it works this way better that
your life
things
yeah also with that yes nothing else i
need to add no i mean that's it that's
it it's it's it's the same thing with
the money stuff we teach you know
borrowers slave to the lender get out of
debt you could just say because the
bible said don't be a slave you know
it's silly don't do it
but you could all go also go oh well
here's what the data says from the
millionaire research study that says
when you do this you're going to have
more likely to be this and and you don't
think like a slave anymore and you tend
to prosper in your in your workplace and
you tend to do this and tend to do that
it's it's very interesting to me and i
just keep going to
i keep going back to that
solving for peace right what are the
things i can do to my oh you gave me
another piece of data
that's good i'm going to go i'm going to
go down that trail because it's going to
help my life be a little bit better i'm
going to do this because to help my life
be a little bit better and it's also
we've got to stop
oh that's a that's a that's a thing
we've been doing for a long time let's
blow it up
we got to stop doing that just because
we got to stop we got to stop yeah
yes i'm a fuddy duddy the problem is i'm
a well informed one
this is the ramsey ship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
mark and stephanie are with us they are
in portland oregon and it says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you so much thank you well done
how much did you pay off
we paid off
705 000
in 144 months wow and your range of
income during that time
we started at forty five thousand and
went up to three hundred and ten
thousand and now back down to 205.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm in software sales
and i used to work at automotive
dealerships as a fixed office director
but now i'm driving a semi truck cool
very cool all right what's the house
worth
um well we paid 400 for it and uh right
now it's worth about 750. awesomeness
and i'm guessing that 705 000 over 12
years you paid off your house
we did sir whoo
how old are you two
we are 39 and 40 years old i love it
and how much in your retirement accounts
we have about 350
so you are baby steps millionaires
yes sir we are i'm so proud of y'all and
not even 40.
that was our goal we set a goal years
ago we wanted to be debt-free by 30 and
we want their house paid off by 40. so
you're millionaires by 40 and people say
rich people stole all their money
where'd you steal yours
[Laughter]
sweat equity sir
how much of this did you inherit because
rich people always inherit all their
money
we did get a small inheritance from my
grandma
after we'd already paid everything off
how much was the small inheritance
it was about 40 000. so it's safe to say
mathematically you did not become
millionaires because of stealing it or
because of an inheritance
no sir we already passed that finish
line before we received it you're pretty
stinking amazing awesome so proud of
y'all how's it feel
it feels pretty incredible
we uh
you know it was kind of a long journey
to get here for sure we had all kinds of
uh
normal weird debt of bedroom furniture
we owed the tool truck for mark's the
job in the car industry and student
loans cars personal loans everything and
um
you know it's been a long road and we
were
really really thankful that we were able
to get to the finish line because it was
um
12 years
a short journey for us yeah 12 years is
a long time but that's a normal track
for paying off a house is 10 to 12 years
that's what we find among millionaires
well done
so how is this altering how you live
because you've been living a certain way
for
more than a decade and now you've got to
live completely different what are y'all
doing differently
you know i think we're still figuring
that out you know after after so long
we've kind of just stuck to it we
we're kind of thinking of maybe doing
some upgrades and things but
right now at least for me
i'm kind of still doing the same thing
here's what's so cool
about being a millionaire and making a
couple hundred thousand dollars a year
and having no payments
is uh
you can do
anything that you want
whenever you want to
that's something we really learned last
year is that we were really heads down
focused on
getting to baby step seven and paying
off the house and we were working a lot
we
you know we're doing everything we could
to reach this goal and we realized that
it was detrimental to our health
especially to mark's health that he was
in the hospital several times from
stress from his job and we sat down and
we said all right well we're six months
away from our goal we want to stick with
it or do we want to
have a life-changing event and pause and
made the decision the next day for mark
to take a pause in his career and he
took five months off and sort of decided
to reset and go a completely different
direction and
had we not been on this program and not
had our emergency fund and everything
set up
you know we wouldn't have had that
option but it was such a blessing to us
to be able to make that life choice for
his health for our family and and we're
in a much better place and we found that
you know making a lot of money while
it's it's difficult it can be done but
that's not what it's about it's about
creating a better life for your family
and yourself well and that's the net
result of the whole thing is you're
controlling the controllables
absolutely so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
paid off your house in 144 months your
baby steps millionaires by the time
you're 40 what's the key to doing all
this
well definitely the budget i will say
that
before we got married
i came from family that didn't watch the
finances and didn't do a budget and when
we were dating mark came from family
that did and and we started to talk
about money and he flat out said to me
he said either you do a budget or we're
done dating because i'm not going to put
up with her for the rest of my life
and
it probably wasn't the best approach i
would recommend europe
you're a real romantic mark
but it definitely got the job done and i
i got on board so the budget definitely
is key
and i'd also say it's good to
give yourself a little bit of grace and
be able to step back a little bit
especially when you're in baby step six
once you've had your nose down for a
while and you're driving towards that
goal it's tough to give yourself
permission to spend but um we definitely
did that along the way you need to
that's the you go from intense to
intentionality when you're in baby steps
four five six
and that's what you're supposed to do
and you guys sounds like you did a
really good job of catching the rhythm
on that well done
very very well done so what's the first
big thing you're gonna do to celebrate
being millionaires and having no debt
house and everything
i am planning on buying a polaris razor
wow that's cool
yeah i've wanted one for about five
years now but it wasn't in the plan but
now it is
i gotta tell you man i've got uh uh
one of the can-am versions and it is a
beast
it is so freaking much i've almost died
a few times with dave driving that thing
around man
they are a blast uh we have one
couple that we're friends with uh also
on baby step seven and they have one and
then i instantly got hooked the first
time i sat in one you should you should
buy that toy that is an awesome toy
and you have earned it i'm so proud of
you guys very very very well done
excellent excellent excellent job
so uh good stuff we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you because you
are one copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to someone and a
one-year membership to financial peace
university you may want to give that
away or you may want to go through it we
the ones are good with us we're happy
for you we're proud of you very very
well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders
probably our biggest cheerleaders are uh
jimmy and candy i'll throw their names
out um
they were that couple that are also on
baby step seven they were actually uh
one of my jimmy's one of my lead techs
at my dealership i worked out and just
somehow we found out we were both on the
plan he was already on baby step seven
and
he just really encouraged me
for the last probably four years to
stick with it
yeah that's good it's good to have
friends that are positive our elp as
well when uh mark quit his job last
summer we were ready to
um you know spend quite a bit to get our
house paid off sooner and he kind of
paused even though it wasn't in his best
interest and said no no no that's that's
not what dave would tell you to do let's
um let's stick to the plan and you know
take your few months and then we'll get
back at it but um you know we're not
going to change things just because of
this so i appreciate the lps as well
yeah that's good that's good very well
done good stuff you guys you're awesome
way to go rock stars
freaking 40 year old millionaires baby
step millionaires house and everything
is paid for that's a way to live right
there mark and stephanie portland oregon
705 000 paid off in
144 months 12 years where i come from 45
000 to 310 back down to 205 on the
income 39 and 40 years old count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a decade-long scream right
there i love it
dave ramsey doesn't teach people how to
become wealthy he just teaches them how
to get out of debt have you heard that
one
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 28 6
better is a poor man who walks in his
integrity than a rich man who is crooked
in his ways
albert einstein said try not to become a
person of success but rather try to
become a person of
value
yes
mike is with us mike's in jupiter
florida hey mike welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up i have a i have a god story
for you real quick and i have a question
at the end of it i was a chemical
engineer in the state of louisiana for
about five years working 80 hours a week
and i just want to be home with with my
wife and kids more often
and the lord really came
into the picture and he really showed up
so my stepdad he's been in commercial
real estate for 35 years
he owned a lot of shopping centers and
sold everything and focused on just one
shopping center about 75 000 square feet
near jupiter florida and so he said hey
how would you like to come work for me
i'm going to retire and teach you the
business and you only have to work 20 30
hours a week and i say where do i sign
so i took over the property and right
after you bought it i remodeled the
whole place i brought it up four years
later we brought up the value from 12
million i brought up the value from 12
million and 30 million dollars and we're
in the process of selling it right now
so my question to you is
he was so gracious enough uh to give me
25 of the company
so when we sell it for 30 30 million i
would get 7.5 million so my question to
you is should i take that 7.5 million
put it in
debt free into another shopping center
and live off the noi or should i take
the 7.5 million
pay the taxes and put it in a
conservative mutual fund
i would put it in a shopping center
okay you know what you're doing i
wouldn't have to pay taxes yeah you can
you can go you can do it
1031 and roll your portion in
correct yeah and so you're going to save
the tax is number one but number two
here's the thing
for someone that knows how to do what
you know how to do and i know how to do
which is manage real estate
and it actually was your job for the
last several years
um you needed you need to uh you've got
45 days in a 1031 to identify the
property and six more months to close on
it
okay okay
now
real estate well-purchased
real estate meaning you get a good buy
on it it's got good upside potential
again you may go back in there you may
you might buy a five million dollar
property and put two and a half into it
okay
uh you may or you may do something other
than that i don't know whatever but real
estate that it that has a good roi
a good rate of uh rate of return our roi
yeah um
includes three as you know three types
of rates of return one is you've got the
increase in value for later that you'll
get
two is you have the cash flow and three
is you have the tax depreciation so a
lot of your cash flow is tax sheltered
but that actually has a cash value
because if you had that kind of cash
coming at you from something else you'd
be paying taxes on it
so that actually saves you actual money
today so those three things together
you probably already know this is called
an internal rate of return an irr
okay
and the irr on my good commercial
properties like you're discussing
is usually between 17 and 20 percent
the cash on cash is usually around 10.
but i've got the appreciation and the
taxes in addition to that tax savings in
addition to that but
real estate has
it
it is uh more complicated
and requires more expertise than simply
dumping the money into a good mutual
fund with a long track record
you can do that blindfolded you can't do
real estate blindfolded and real
estate's going to require more of your
time
uh i mean this is thursday as you and i
are talking and i have already four
hours of my week this week invested in
messing with my real estate stuff
and i don't even run it my son-in-law
runs it but i mean we've we've got
development going on we've got purchases
we've got sales we've got things going
on with our real estate portfolio and so
i've been in several different meetings
already this week that total about four
hours of my time the number of hours i
spent on my mutual funds this week is
precisely zero
right so there's a hassle factor and
you're going to invest time
and but you should if you know what
you're doing and it sounds like you have
been mentored well you should make more
money and you're not going to have to
pay the taxes for now by doing a 1031.
so definitely doing another shopping
center if i'm you
okay you're talking about strips you're
talking about strip centers right
correct i was talking about scripts and
so our key was and and what he's taught
me he's not your typical landlord and he
was a great a business mentor for me and
he really taught me the ropes because he
taught me he said hey
let's turn if you have a 3 000 square
foot bay
and they can't pay rent you can only go
up so much he said first of all you got
to have parking i've seen so many
shopping centers with just two rows of
parking well there's only so many people
that can go in there and that in turn
you can only charge your tenant so much
because they're only getting so much
foot traffic you've got to have the
parking there and he taught me 1000
square foot bays is the key because if
you go up from 20 to 30 a foot that's
only five more dollars i mean five more
i mean i'm sorry 20 to 25
that's only 400 more dollars a month
well he always said you can't afford if
you can't afford 400 a month you never
had a business yeah so so is he what's
he going to do with his money
uh he's gonna
he's you know he's 76 years old he he
can't
he can't really move around too good
anymore so he's just gonna put it in his
a trust uh by the way he's got uh two
ten-year-old twins
by a surrogate mother
listen if you do whatever you want to do
um yeah but uh like i said my son-in-law
runs all of our stuff and so if i were
in the old man's shoes i might reinvest
with you
now that i've trained you
right but i'm not saying he needs to but
i i personally that's what i do
obviously um uh
now winston doesn't have the ownership
position that you would have
but uh but he will have when i'm dead
but the uh
but the uh uh
yeah so anyway the the uh
yeah yes you should do real estate and
those are all the reasons
so would you would you as the
uncle in this situation
that'd be a cool cup of coffee to say
hey i would like to propose that you
take the
your windfall from the sale and invest
it in me
moving forward or let me manage your
profit if you want to if you want if you
want to do another deal i'll run it for
you yeah because you taught me how yeah
and um and that way he didn't have to
pay taxes either that's right today or
real and really it's gonna be his kids
yeah you're doing you're running it for
the kids and you know and you can leave
that piece of property in the trust to
the twins yeah
um in that situation so as easy as you
can leave mutual funds now property's
harder to divide up you know you end up
selling the property if you everybody
wants their cash right later on in an
estate situation but
um
but yeah it's a wonderful blessing so
ken coleman talks about this all the
time and we just witnessed it here
the art of the apprenticeship has just
about died in america
and we just witnessed it happening well
there right
now it's not what you would think of as
a craftsman apprenticeship
a woodworking apprenticeship or a metal
working apprenticeship a sculpturing
apprenticeship but that was a real
estate apprenticeship that's what
happened there an internship so to speak
and he paid him well for running the
thing and uh walked him right in there
and then basically handed him
uh seven figures so it's pretty pretty
sweet well and gave him some
really some ownership stake in it a
small amount right but
hey if you go do well and you work hard
and use these principles i'm teaching
you you're going to benefit too yeah
it's not a small amount of seven million
yeah
something's pretty big i would say
percentage-wise but yeah yeah but i mean
he didn't give him he didn't give him uh
controlling interest you know but uh so
and
hats off to mike too for being humble
enough to step in under
um
under uh a master
carpenter to learn carpentry yeah a lot
of folks that walk in at 26 and say i
should oh i should be the president yeah
submit yourself snowflake yeah you know
to to someone who's older and wiser and
learn something it's good that's really
good stuff bro
that's a beautiful thing that happened
there all the way around the triple win
so many things positive about that
yeah and we could all take a art out of
that book and learn something from it
very very powerful and we're seeing a
lot of that now with people
uh abandoning higher education moving
towards the trades we're gonna see more
of that in the trades thank goodness
people needing workers saying hey i'll
train you come come come follow me for
the next two years and show you how to
do it i'll show you how to do it yeah
very cool
if i stay here long enough maybe you
will have mentored me on how to do this
i i'm slowly learning how to do radio
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you